good day I'm Colonel Gerry Morlock the
director of the combat studies institute
you're about to use a video series which
our instructors have prepared for the
sole purpose of improving your
presentation of M 610 the evolution of
modern warfare we've taken care to make
the course that you teach is similar to
the one taught at Fort Leavenworth as
possible and choose to add these tapes
to your libraries in order to give you
every advantage as you prepare to teach
this new course these tapes are similar
to the weekly train obsessions which we
utilize to prepare our instructors here
at Fort Leavenworth my intent for the
tape sessions was to provide you
insights and tips on ways to approach
the lessons of M 6:10 that were not
available in the instructor notes I've
drawn various instructors military and
civilian into the sessions based upon
their specific expertise and historical
background they were asked to just talk
to the lesson structure and content
giving you some additional information
on the historical context and differing
views on how to approach the lessons
these tapes will provide you a wealth of
knowledge and direction that will
significantly improve your readiness to
teach our new history course one word of
caution regarding how to use these
training tapes they are not designed to
be substituted for your instruction
during the individual lessons of the
course as instructor preparation tapes
train-the-trainer material if you will
they are inappropriate for direct
instruction to students and are not
intended for that purpose our intent
with these tapes is to improve your
ability to lead the students seminars by
sharing tips and advice from some highly
qualified experts
the combat Studies Institute stands
ready to provide whatever additional
expertise or assistance that you may
require and we've included the
Institute's phone mail and email contact
information on the tape if you should
need it good luck with evolution of
modern warfare course have a good time
greetings and welcome to lesson 14 which
deals with Vietnam and Afghanistan my
name is dr. George Gaborik joining me
today will be Lieutenant Colonel duck
Skylark and dr. Gerald Brown the Vietnam
War plays a very important part in our
military history you could see its
effects even today just think about
Desert Shield and Desert Storm where our
generals talked about Vietnam this being
not another Vietnam and if you look at
officer corps today we find a split a
good number of officers fought in
Vietnam but that number is slowly
diminishing and if we look at most of
the officer corps what they have is just
memories from others of what this war
was about and what we'd like to do today
is look at some key issues to help
grapple with an important war in our
country's history and remove some of the
myths that have been handed down about
the war and after we do that we'll look
at another major topic which will be
Afghanistan and make some comparisons
and contrast it with Vietnam so that
we'll better get a better idea about the
war in Vietnam
let's put this war in a context let me
be just very brief about this we are in
the era of the Cold War but we
definitely have competition with the
communist world for influence around the
world we're in the policy of containment
we want to prevent the Communists from
spreading their influence around the
world and one place where we come to
blows with the threat from communism is
in Vietnam this is going to be our
longest war some will say in our history
I've identified three major things we'll
be looking at themes that will help
generate broader discussion first one is
what kind of war are we involved in this
clause that says if you're going to get
involved in a war know what kind of war
it is same as if you're going to get
married
know who the person you're going to get
married to is so it will remove some of
the problems initially in getting into a
marriage then we'll look at what were
the u.s. goals strategies and tactics in
this war and then we'll end by looking
at how good were the North Vietnamese
communists because we do have all sorts
of different interpretations of how good
they were and how bad we were and we'll
use those same questions then as we look
at Afghanistan and the Soviet
involvement there so let me first start
out by asking the big broad question
what kind of war is this if you remember
when we talked about the American
Revolution we found that there were
different kinds of wars in this larger
war called the American Revolution there
was a global war eventually involving
Britain and fighting against France the
Dutch Spaniards there was a civil war
aspect to the American Revolution there
was guerrillas fighting against
conventional forces and conventional
forces fighting against conventional
forces this was a very complex war as
was Vietnam how would you answer the
question what kind of war was Vietnam
well George I think there's a this is
one of the one of the better questions
and something that puzzles many people
that don't really look deeply into the
Vietnam War frequently to begin with we
overlook the strategic context this war
is part of an international political
struggle it's a cold war war
first and foremost that's what gets us
there that's a what puts us against pits
us against the the North Vietnamese and
and their cousins in the Vietcong in the
south and in that context you if you
don't appreciate that you cannot
appreciate the strategic and operational
approach that the United States takes
some of the things we do over there
don't have don't make any sense at all
unless you consider that this is a cold
war war so you've got to consider the
international political struggle I think
the main point to be brought out with
that too is that because it's an
international war it means the people
will be fighting on the ground will be
getting support from China and the
Soviet Union which allow them to sustain
the war effort much longer than if they
were working just with their own
resources right we are we're not
fighting the Vietnamese
over regional hegemony as much as we are
fighting the Soviet Union through their
proxies the Vietnamese and to some
extent the Chinese through their proxies
the Vietnamese although as we discover
later that they're not as tight and all
tied together as as we originally
appreciate it or thought back in the 50s
I think you've got to understand that
context though now when you get into the
warrant that's where you start wondering
and that's what really drives the
confusion when you get into an
operational context of how this war is
carried out or a strategic level
operational versus the national policy
level question if you are in the Air
Force for you this might be considered a
strategic bombing campaign we're trying
to take out the infrastructure of North
Vietnam through such intensive bombing
that they come to the peace table
unwilling to continue the war and for
the for the Air Force this is more they
would like it to be primarily a war of
strategic bombing same thing they've
done to Nazi Germany and to Japan during
the Second World War
what the Air Force too has got a part in
other role in other facets of the war
there's the interdiction campaign the
bombing of the Ho Chi Minh Trail the
notion that we can if we can stop the
north from supplying the south we can
handle the problem in the south so
there's that aspect of it now the Air
Force isn't alone in that particular
role of the strategic bombings largely
them in the Navy but when you get into
the interdiction campaign Air Force Navy
and also to an extent ground troops do
that in the interdiction campaign Ho Chi
Minh Trail everybody knows about but
it's also going down in the south and
also along the coastline so they're
trying to keep the north away from the
south and that's another work we can
just hold off reinforcements we can win
this war then there's the war of the
main force battle that's primarily the
ground war and that is the war of the
North Vietnamese invading the south
that's the battalion regimental size war
is the large offenses that we see in way
you know the Battle of Tet the mang the
real big name battles of the war where
the North Vietnamese regulars mix it up
with with South beat the South
Vietnamese Army in the American armies
and Marines on the ground
at a very large and costly scale finally
there's the camp the pacification
campaign or the village of war at war of
the VC that makes so much about
particularly in America today you know
you don't know who the enemy was over
there the little boy who who's had your
pet and you give him the chocolate bar
and as you walk away he throws a grenade
at you okay the the war of the South
Vietnamese people that were sympathetic
to the north the Vietcong versus the
North Vietnamese regular war and all of
these are going on simultaneously and
all of them are interrelated and
integrated but for an observer that
tries to figure out you know what is
this Vietnam or about it can leave you
pretty confused you know if you if you
go get an Air Force generals briefing
you'll get one perspective if you go ask
a grunt and a rice paddy what's this war
about you get something entirely
different
the point you're making is a very
confused or compared some of the other
wars that we have studied in the past in
which the issues are not clear the sides
are not distinctly separate for example
as you point out it's very difficult
sometimes to separate the Vietcong North
Vietnamese forces even though they may
fight differently even though they are
fighting
perhaps for different causes this is a
very confused and we need to understand
that that's one thing that makes this
war different
some of the other words that we had view
in the past in this course some other
ways that you might look at what kind of
war is this in addition to the
International dimension of it is to look
at is how much is it conventional war or
counter insurgency it involves an
invasion from the north and we have to
fight against the north vietnamese but
the problem is we don't take the war to
north vietnam so that not on the ground
not on the ground and then you've got
the problem that there's the civil war
aspect to it it starts out with south
vietnamese against south vietnamese with
support from the north but because the
north doesn't invade with a large
conventional for us to occupy part of
the country but infiltrates it makes it
a mercury or then if you just crossed
the DMZ and occupy the northern part and
then said ok fight us in a conventional
sense
so what that does is it creates a
complexity and confusion about what kind
of war are we involved in and the
dynamics of how much is it conventional
unconventional how much is a civil war
versus conventional war will change as
time goes on it means then that as
you're fighting against the North
Vietnamese and the South Vietnamese
Vietcong it means you have to try
different kinds of things because you
just can't isolate it I only fight one
kind of war to exclude the others and
assume that if you just win that part
everything else will fall into place
which is sometimes a major mistake that
writers make when they talk about the
war and try to analyze it we also have
to look
the coalition nature of this will
absolutely try that we have the
expectation of many people looking at
Vietnam in the first time this focusing
exclusively on the United States not
only is the United States there fighting
we do have an ally in the republic of
south vietnam we also have a number of
our other allies at various times the
australians will have forces on the
ground
the Koreans will actually send troops to
South Vietnam to fight
and so we have to understand this isn't
a coalition effort on our part as well
as confiding a very confused enemy we
also have to look at this as a regional
conflict it's a very difficult problem
for us to sort out what's going on in
countries such as Cambodia and Laos both
of whom will play a increasing role in
this war as time moves on to the point
that the United States and its allies
will make incursions into both of these
countries eventually in an attempt to
deal with both the state even aspect of
those countries and the use of those
countries by the North Vietnamese to
shuttle supplies into the south so
that's another expanding dimension of
this war as we go through the later
1960s and the early 1970s excellent why
we move on to the next broader theme
which is what were the u.s. goals what
strategies to employ what tactics that
we use what was our goal in Vietnam did
we have a clear one
how would you answer that that's that's
one of the one of the great debatable
questions and you have a spectrum of
answers one of course the first and
foremost one that's proposed to the
American people is you got to draw the
line
the Communists have been steadily
expanding since the Second World War
Eastern Europe had fallen to communism
they had made inroads into the northern
part of Korea which the United States
you know blocked in 1950 it had been
steadily being propagated in in Asia as
well as parts of eastern and southern
Europe and the United States saw its
role in the world as to stop this
communist expansion this is about the
time the domino theory comes into effect
early 50s and it's it's almost got the
power of law written law by my 60s where
one of these little countries Falls if
South Vietnamese goes down South Vietnam
goes down it's going to take em beaudion
layouts with it and then Thailand and
then the whole region goes down
and at the strategic the macro level the
national level our goal is to stop that
okay but when we do that our goal is
really defensive in nature
we're not going to try to overthrow for
example the North Vietnamese we're
certainly not going to try to do
anything against the Chinese you know
the Korean War made that very clear that
despite our great technological advances
any war in those directions is going to
be very costly so it's primarily at the
strategic level a very defensive goal we
are containing the expansion of
communism and to a large extent were
that's monolithic communism red is the
red is a red be he Russian or polish or
Chinese or Korean or North Vietnamese
they all all the same and we don't like
Tommy isn't that right that's right
that's a good point
what you've done is the basic goal is to
prevent communism from spreading and
in there you could phrase it as we want
to preserve an independent non communist
South Vietnam but you've added to it a
lot of meat substance which is with a
defensive strategy we're afraid of
getting involved in a larger war we
misread the Chinese during a camera in
war MacArthur the great fail out there
in Asia said the Chinese are not going
to get involved they did get involved so
we're concerned about this war spreading
too much and getting the Chinese
involved so we limit ourselves it's a
defensive posture that we're taking to
preserve the government in South Vietnam
from falling to the combat at the
national level again in different levels
of war you can have a national strategy
of defense but at a military strategic
level below that you can use offensive
operations to support that defense you
know so it varies back and forth
depending upon what level you're at at
least at the very highest level again
we're not trying to overthrow the
communist governments that is a
defensive strategy now what goes along
with that when you say that is a clauser
which tells us you know you can't win
the war without offensive actions so at
the very highest level of national
strategy we're fighting a defensive war
which takes all of the national
strategic initiative and places it
firmly in the lap of the North
Vietnamese they get to decide when they
want to stop attacking when they when
they when they've had enough
and if they decide they're never gonna
have enough you know what goes on
forever because we're not going to do
anything positive to stop them from
doing take one way to as you look at
strategy to try to implement that
political goal of preserving South
Vietnam preventing it from falling there
are two parts to it there's the
non-military political side of strategy
and then there's the military strategy
what can we say about the kinds of
strategies we employ in this war on the
political side one that comes to mind is
we're going to have - as time goes on
strengthen the South Vietnamese
government and as this war drags on we
have to make it more legitimate we'll
talk about having elections to give it
legitimacy we'll talk about questions of
reform we'll talk about issues of
financial reform try to attack the
corruption that is important because if
the government is weak the army on the
South Vietnamese side is weak and means
we have to do more so we have to work
the political side in conjunction what's
happening in the military side one can't
win without the other working well and
this is a problem that we face when we
look at fighting this war on the
strategic level political military
interface
any other comments of course our
legacies the post-world War two period
the basic philosophical underpinnings of
such things as a Marshall Plan and the
Truman Doctrine are inherently tied up
the policies that we pursue in Southeast
Asia we don't invent these policies for
Southeast Asia or for South Vietnam they
have all in some way has been tried and
tested in previous conflicts the ideas
the legitimacy the ideas of economic
viability all of these have have their
antecedents and at this point there's no
reason to believe that they won't work
let's not judge the ends by what we see
people attempting to do in the late
1950s the mid 1960s all of these things
were before and the hip proved
themselves so you're trying them again
the fact that they're not going to work
in Vietnam should not deter us from
judging them and terms of what is going
on from the time the United States
begins to assume a role in Southeast
Asia in the mid 1950s until we become
involved in a full-blown ground war by
the mid-nineteen systems if you look to
the dilemma that the military faces on
the strategic side we cannot go after
the center of gravity in Hanoi with
ground forces
we basically follow a strategy of
attrition trying to wear down the enemy
killing him destroying as much of his
resources so he'll give up and in that
comes the measure that you have of how
well you're doing because it can't be
just holding terrain because we're your
troops are not it's up for grabs as we
get into a body count what do you think
about the whole notion of a strategy of
attrition as a way we fight this taking
it down to the level of measurement that
we're doing well becomes the body count
which has all sorts of problems related
to that concept
I think our I think our strategy
devolved and you know if we can't do
what we want to do we'll do what we can
do we'll want to do what we can do and
if we're not permitted by our political
masters to take the war to the North
Vietnamese for all sorts of reasons that
are seem to be well-founded based on
recent history you know the Chinese went
into Korea when they got nervous about
the integrity of the North Korean
government and territory what's to say
it's not going to happen here again so
for pretty good political military
reasons of at least on the surface the
military is not going to be permitted to
do some of the things that it would like
to do and it kind of finds itself in the
in the realm of well if if you can't
take enemy ground away from him in which
is something that's measurable and
you really can't say who controls any
one piece of ground outside of the major
cities at least in the early 60s you
know you control wherever you send
American soldiers and when you leave it
with those soldiers you no longer
control it okay so you can't really
measure capturing ground in the south
because you can't be everywhere so what
can you measure and we kind of fall into
well we know when we kill up when we
kill somebody we know that guy's not
going to fight us anymore and if you
take a an approach up well there's only
so many of these folks and we got
population statistics they're going to
reach a point where their population can
no longer support the war theory and
that point becomes what Westmoreland
will call the crossover point the light
at the end of the tunnel where the North
Vietnamese effort will steadily be
declining through lack of lack of troops
anymore it's not pretty it's not the way
the army would like to do business or
the or the US military would like to do
business but it sees that that's all
it's got open to it it's its only
options okay but that's the strictly
military enough that doesn't get into
the political side of things you know
the establishment of the legitimacy in
which we've been trying to do since the
the elections were called off in 54 and
you know the initial underpinnings of
the next Vietnam or after the French 56
elections running those we'll call up
and the underpinnings of the next war
start forming and then we try all sorts
of things to establish the legitimacy of
the North Korea the South Vietnamese
government not only in Vietnam itself
but also in the United States you know
diem is build to the American people as
a George Washington of South Vietnam you
know and it kind of shows were a little
a little out of touch with those you
know here is a Catholic you know being
being billed as the founding father if
you will of a new democracy in a
primarily Buddhist country with his
little little contingent of you know
little government based on prac you know
nepotism so we're not we're not dealing
with that very well and by the time diem
is assassinated you know and around the
time Kennedy's assassinated there's not
a whole lot of folks in the United
States that are gonna cry for him but
then he's succeeded by a series of
generals strong generals that replace
each other
and you know the legitimacy falls off
there what are we fighting for in
Vietnam if we can't even say that the
South Vietnamese government is
legitimate you know it almost it's like
a banana republic you know they turn
over military dictators every year and
bringing groups of them and disband them
in another so
that's hard for the military to deal
with and it's not entirely the
military's place to deal with that kind
of thing but it falls into the you know
how do you deal with this problem with
strategically for them for the US
military it becomes a matter of well we
can't touch that kind of thing we can't
make this guy legitimate or anybody
running that state legitimate we can't
do what we like to do militarily invade
the north well what can we do we can
kill up in the south and we can count
how many we kill and our our strategy is
channeled you know and becomes ever
narrower until that's all we've gotten
is go find him first world war
a prime example in which states fight
each other until they they are both
exhausted one being more exhausted than
the other
problem for the United States is clearly
forgotten that less than a half a
century earlier that states once they
are ginned up and once they are
committed are capable of fighting to
tremendous degree of loss etc so the
problem with attrition is like as a
policy is nobody can tell you in advance
how many of these people we have to kill
anybody's we have to stack up in order
to be successful well the way we go
about it is an attrition strategy of not
how much he can stand
implying that how much how much killing
do we need to do to affect his will
we're focused more on his his material
capability how much can we kill so that
what he can bring to bear against us is
insignificant we never try to get into
the heads the North Vietnamese
leadership to understand them we keep
trying to influence I'm will will send
them a signal by having a couple of days
of bombing campaign and will draw the
the circle of the protected circle
around Hanoi way a little bit tighter
well I'm a little bit closer to their
home you know their capital and will let
them know that we really mean business
and it will stop and we'll wait for
their reaction but we never try to
figure out are they reacting to this
what do they see when we bomb them and
then stop bombing we think we're sending
signals of power they think we're weak
we don't have the willpower to do this
carry this work through to victory and
do what's needed to be done to win
there's there's a wonderful line in Dave
Palmer's book summons of the trumpet
where he talks about the American as
attrition strategy and he says you know
attrition is not a strategy
but he's wrong attrition is a strategy
is it's the North Vietnamese strategy
not all the time they try they try wars
of conquest and you know Tet certainly
is about gaining all that land and they
lose that battle but over the long haul
what's winning for them is an attrition
strategy and historically attrition
strategies are the strategy of the
weaker side so we ourselves as the
militarily stronger side in this war
adopted the strategy of weakness that
our enemy then played to the hilt
attrition should be recognized and also
being more than just body count you
refer to yes versus nutrition-wise to
resources as well the Air Force for
example is bombing campaign ignore
focused on the petroleum industry is one
of its targets with the clear objective
of
reducing or eliminating petroleum as a
resource to the north the problem for
the war was that petroleum was not an
important element in the North
Vietnamese resourcing in the south most
of the supplies that goes out goes south
on trucks it goes south for bicycles
I'm sold by going after the wrong target
you can in fact eliminate or at least
reduce significantly but it may not make
it make a difference sure and to try to
go about this war saying well you know
for the Germans you know bombing those
Romanian oil fields will stop the
Panzers well that's true but like you're
saying this is this is a people powered
army even if you went to the technology
that they used the arms industry you
know the weapons who's making the ak-47
you don't bomb the ak-47 factories
because they're in China and they're in
there in Russia who help and check us a
lot that's right Eastern Europe so
you can't play by the same rules that we
played by particularly in the strategic
bombing but it creeps into our thought
all across the spectrum of this war
somehow we are trying to make this the
type of war we want it to be make it the
kind of war we want to fight because
that's the kind where we're good at and
they just will not they will cooperate
it gets us to talking about the North
Vietnamese and how good were they what
were their strategies and tactics I
think one way to look at it is that
there are an active player and they
influence what we do we have to react to
them and they have to react to us the
war has its conventional aspects its
unconventional aspects as a conventional
war plus counterinsurgency for us for
the North Vietnamese they can play
either one depending on what we're doing
the dilemma we face is the more we try
to make it conventional and build up our
large forces to try to get them to do
the big battle if it's not to their
favor they're going to go into small
unit tactics guerrilla activities if we
go too much chasing after them in small
units with small units then we run the
risk of them messing some power over
running a few posts out there in left
field so to speak and the political
fallout back in the United States is
would be devastating we don't want
another DnB in phu or anything on a
smaller scale so we face the dilemma
here the more conventional we go the a
smart opponent opponent determined that
through the long haul will go
unconventional the more we chase them
with counterinsurgency the more he's
going to shift over and look for an
opportunity to some big damage with big
units to us so this is I think one thing
to keep in mind as we look at this a
whole notion of the enemy's not past if
he's active and he could do things and
force us to adjust to him and this is I
think how the North Vietnamese have
options to allow them with their strong
will to keep this the long haul as long
as it takes
to tribe numerous different kinds of
things that make this a long drawn-out
war but how smart are they in all this
as they're adjusting because my strategy
has to adjust their strategy has to just
same with our tactics and their tactics
so the problem is not the adjustment
it's analyzing how good was the
adjustment don't criticize because we've
changed a bit our strategy because we
had to in response to the enemy were we
adjusting properly to meet his
adjustments is the one issue you ought
to keep in mind what about the North
Vietnamese how smart are they is this a
long drawn-out plan that they have that
comes to fruition at the end with a
victory or are they making mistakes and
stumbling through like we're kind of
stumbling through trying to understand
this strange creature called the
Vietnamese war
I think there's there's two real good
questions in there or two real good
issues one is who are they when we say
the North Vietnamese we're making an
assumption that everybody in Hanoi I
bought the same way and we do that just
like we think all communists think alike
because we don't know any better and we
don't try to find out throughout this
war would never make a serious effort to
find out who our enemy is
they have dissension in the ranks
serious dissension about how this war
should be fought particularly after Tet
when the United States is doing
tremendous damage to their war effort
we never know about that
and we never try to find out what kind
of things are going on in the enemy's
head you know they are not a modernist
you know being that has one direction in
one direction only and when division
that is present is the one how
conventional should we go how
unconventional that's a one burning
issue we have the same kind of division
within the political side how do you
employ the military on the military side
how should we be employed you've got
differences between Marines Army and Air
Force and how we approach this so we're
not monolithic either as well as they
are not they're like us having tensions
conflicting views on how to wage this
war and that answers the second part of
this question many Americans and it
seems to be part of the popular culture
about Vietnam right now is that they
played one strategy the entire war the
North Vietnamese played one strategy and
it was a strategy of patience and
nutrition and the United States was
pretty well doomed from the start to
fail to the to this strategy they were
you know the Vietnamese were going to
beat us great jokes that Western
journalists used to tell when it's when
they see new American commanders coming
in to Vietnam about here comes another
great western warrior about to lose his
reputation to generals yup and Ho Chi
Minh and
they build up a myth about the enemy
this this myth of infallibility that's
just not true it's almost like
Montgomery Field Marshal Montgomery in
Africa in the Second World War has to
pass a pass in order to his army to stop
talking about general Rommel
he's got the he's got the Brits so cowed
that he mark every forbids them to speak
his name you almost see the head in
Vietnam
this notion that they don't make
mistakes and yet they do make mistakes
you know they're first and foremost
mistake is they think we're the French
you know they they treat our firebases
our outpost as if they were French
outposts you know they would they would
attack them and try to draw in
reinforcements and ambush the
reinforcements and destroy them but our
reinforcements aren't travelling
primarily by trucks we have armored
columns and we have helicopters and it
takes them a long long time to deal with
that and figure out how to fight that we
have firepower the French never dreamed
of right den bien phu you know the
French asked for a stand up battle gee
up gave them a stand up battle gee up
out gun the French at the type of battle
they wanted to do they try the same
thing with the United States and Danang
and other places hamburger hill you name
it they try to stand up battle with
American forces and they are squashed
hands down every time
we're not the French it takes them a
long time to figure that out
that's a major bone of contention
between G op who's trying to play
replays earlier victories and his
detractors who are saying you can't
treat the Americans like the French
they're slaughtering our folks we need
to go back to a lower level conflict so
this notion of the infallibility of
other of the Communists and I group the
Vietcong in with the North Vietnamese
they're over there certainly two
different different entities
it just doesn't play out if you get into
and study this war those are excellent
points recent scholarship gives I think
a much better appreciation of the Tet
Offensive and their strategy there was a
debate should we continue on
conventional or should we go more
conventional and job argued that the
time was right for the major uprising we
attacked in numerous places at the same
time we being the North Vietnamese we
could do serious damage to the South
Vietnamese government and its forces we
can cause the popular uprising and I'll
leave the Americans holding on to
nothing so he argues let's go for the
gusto
let's go during Tet and the attack and
they're focusing on winning the war
really quickly what they find is were
able to do damage to them the South
Vietnamese government and troops do
damage to the North Vietnamese some
people probably in the cities might have
voted for Ho Chi Minh an election but
when they see rebels coming out of the
hills they're gonna fight to protect
their city and join the South Vietnamese
forces no popular uprising what it does
it leads to a tremendous loss of people
on the North Vietnamese side job looks
bad his position within the Politburo
drops it's a failed strategy
particularly in the Vietcong it kind of
in Congress extreme is suffering a lot
exactly good but all of a sudden
discontent
emerges in the united states to new
levels north vietnamese slowly moved to
exploit the growing discontent back in
the united states but we were not a
target meaning the public in the united
states was not a target for this tet
offensive point but they stumbled into
it they were flexible enough and
adjusted to be able to take advantage of
it in the long run so it's not that
they're smart but they're flexible it's
not that they have this great drawn-out
strategy but they have the will to keep
trying banging their head if they have
to and those things flexibility and
determination can sometimes hide error
from a distance weakness right certainly
when
Johnson goes to Vietnam in 1967 he comes
back and presents himself to the
American people was having been to
Vietnam
having confirmed himself that everything
is under control
and then the disaster falls upon his
head there's a major factor in the
entrance of other contenders into the
1968 Democratic primaries in a decision
in April of 1968 for Johnson to pull out
of the presidency those those errors on
our side play right into the hands well
certainly it all goes back I think to
knowing your enemy well yes a very good
point but but this this notion that well
we see the we see the light at the end
of the tunnel in 1967 they use that term
it captures the public imagination we're
winning you know we might not be there
yet but there's progress we're gonna win
this thing they'll hide at the end of
the time tunnel the enemy's capabilities
are falling off we never asked the enemy
about that just like throughout world
war ii german capabilities are steadily
falling off as they're retreated on the
Eastern Front and then later on the
Western Front but five months before the
war ends there they are launching the
Battle of the Bulge a massive offensive
that they could afford to lose those
troops no but they were desperate okay
in 1968 by our assessment perhaps they
never should have done the Tet Offensive
and by some Vietnamese assessment after
the battle they said they think they
never should have done it
but we never hell out for the capability
that they could have done it and the
very fact that the 1968 election becomes
a referendum on war right indication to
what extent it has reached into the
streets of America but although as you
learn out earlier George that was not
the intention right right and and again
it goes back to knowing yourself to what
is the referendum on the war okay there
are many Americans that are very
dissatisfied with the war to LBJ's mind
and to others that dissatisfaction means
they want us to get out
popular polls show that even at the time
of Ted if not a majority very close to a
majority of the American people were in
favor of continuing the war if the
United States pursued a strategy that
would bring it to victory
it wasn't a nationwide peace movement as
some would have you believe the day next
campaign promised in 1968 which brings
him to victory he has a plan that's
right I have a plan here peace with
honor
and that sells a presidency I think the
thing to keep in mind when I talk about
the public no matter how noble the war
effort is I'm thinking of world war two
a president has to worry about public
opinion he has to worry to keep the
people focused on the war effort we saw
that in the Civil War the noble quest by
Lincoln Union well the war is dragging
on and on and election this coming
people like grant and Sherman are
worried that Lincoln might not get
reelected there's a quote unquote peace
candidate they're striving to get to
Atlanta to give it as a gift to Lincoln
to help him with his reelection FDR has
to keep Americans focused on the primary
enemy Germany not on Japan we got to get
soldiers on the ground in North Africa
to start fighting there rather than keep
worrying about the Pacific all those
kinds of things are very important to
keep in mind in any kind of war you have
to what rekindle the spirit to keep the
loyalty of the people for the word for
in Vietnam
nowhere unusual in this regard it's just
that the kind of war that it is it's
difficult to bring concrete results
quickly and the people start to fade
away we need to now fade away into a new
subject which has a lot of reading
Afghanistan let me throw out a few
things to consider and then I open up
for discussion if you were around in
1979 and the Soviets were going into
Afghanistan the feeling would be among
major analysts that the Soviets are
going to have an easy time winning in
Afghanistan they were not going to have
the problems we had in Vietnam they were
going to show us how to do it if you
looked at some of the arguments that
were made on the Soviet side the
advantages that they had one they had a
totalitarian system they would not allow
for public discontent to emerge there
was not allow for a free press to
critique what is going on in Afghanistan
if things went badly it was in their
national interest it wasn't like
thousands of miles away in some
godforsaken land but it's mortaring
right on the Soviet Union because it's
close they would have easy time with
just across the border they would be
able to call upon their own Muslims
within their own country who know
Muslims in Afghanistan some of them
speak the same language so there
wouldn't be this great cultural gap
between the Soviet effort and people
they were fighting the Afghans and when
they actually got to the point of the
arrow they could Newcombe if they needed
to they could probably throw chemicals
at them they could do all sorts of
crosses because they wouldn't have the
moral restraints that we had to fight
under in Vietnam these were some of the
points that were made and then when they
looked at the Afghan side the Afghans
are no North Vietnamese they don't have
this cane or a center of gravity a safe
haven they could only be reached by
bombing they're not unified like the
North Vietnamese communists who have a
Politburo we have a party who control
the military they're fragmented the
ragheads and they have primitive more
primitive weapons versus what the
sophisticated North Vietnamese have
these were the kinds of jargon these
kind of stereotypes these kind of
prejudices almost racial statements that
were being made during this time and the
people were surprised that the war
dragged on and on and on until the
according to the Afghan rebels they
helped put one nail in the Soviet coffin
because of the war effort in Afghanistan
the training of resources they help
bring the Soviet empire down one of the
things I think you could do is talk over
some of these things that were strengths
for the Soviets and another thing that
you then might say as in anything
nothing is invincible in every strength
there's also a weakness for example the
totalitarian system marshal said
democracy cannot stand a seven years war
I would argue a totalitarian system
would have a hard time fighting a seven
years war because it costs money does
the Soviet Union have wealth resources
to fight that log and still worry about
the main threat which is us in NATO
that's where their primary focus is even
though they're fighting down in
Afghanistan sure it's in their interest
but if it takes too long you start
wondering how important is that if red
lines are getting longer our economy is
hurting we need to get out because
though it's next door we could go down
from within if we don't solve the
problem I'm sure you have Muslims in
your own society but what kind of
Muslims do you have the ones you're
going to listen to a communist they're
apparat snakes they're people who moved
up in the system by the Soviet ideology
I probably feel very distant from the
Afghan rebels so you don't have a
cultural insight into the Afghans as a
communist member sitting in Moscow
directing the war effort there that is
not to your advantage
sure it's next door need a logistics
base but it's your weakest one of your
weakest areas for a logistics base you
can drive across the border but there
are only a few roads that can be used
and the rebels can interdict them sure
the rebels are using more primitive
weapons they're fragmented it's sort of
in a way their strength is to fight with
fragmentation I like to think of them as
divided we stand united we fall the
strength in resisting has been a more
diversified decentralized way of
execution of fighting and they don't
present a convenience and our gravity
target there are too many many centers
of gravity in the different rebels and
tribes that deep down inside they want
to fight and because you come in as an
outsider almost from the word get-go 99
percent 98 percent maybe 95 percent of
population is against you because they
don't like foreigners their history is
one of resisting so you've got everybody
turned against you whereas in Vietnam we
had a lot of people who did not want a
communist victory just that we couldn't
give them a victory fast enough
so those are the things that are some of
the things you might consider about sure
it's important to remember to every
strength there's a weakness and it can
be exploited and this is what the Afghan
resistance does it eventually turns all
those strengths into weaknesses on the
Soviet side I think there are some the
way you started off there was a natural
tendency by particularly Americans
particularly American military people
and military commentators to look at the
Soviet invasion of Afghanistan and look
at our own recent experience in Vietnam
and you know the notion it was military
people that were saying the Soviets are
going to show us how it should have been
done and maybe we made some of the they
made some of the same
mistakes that we made in not
understanding what they were dealing
with when they went into Afghanistan you
know they were going in for a quick
incursion stabilized the government and
they were going to be out of there and
they found themselves in a much bigger
problem than they'd ever anticipated
because they didn't give enough time to
thinking about what it is they were
getting themselves involved with it goes
back to that first strategic question
that Clausewitz tells you to ask
yourself if you're going to go to war
what kind of war you're going to get
yourself into for for the Americans is
this thing dragged on we there become
more and more points of comparison
between it and Vietnam and it's useful
to look at them and then I think you
know do some contrasting as well just as
the Soviets you know one of the points
of contrast is there they're right there
next to Afghanistan you know they're
contiguous with it you can launch from
Soviet territory right into Afghanistan
for the rebels there's there's some
benefits to their contiguous with
Pakistan an ally of ours and there's
weapons flowing freely and so there is a
comparison with it through the Vietnam
War there you know the arms are coming
in and the Soviets find themselves in
the same position we were in we could
not at least openly bomb lay house in
Cambodia although we certainly did it
covertly the Soviets cannot palm
Pakistan because then they'll get us mad
and that kind of goes to why they don't
use the nukes either you know they
couldn't hide right bombing Iran or
Pakistan but we could hide our
involvement in Cambodia to a large
extent for a while right well and it
goes to kind of the way they used their
weapons to you don't see nuclear weapon
use in in Afghanistan pretty hard to
hide that you know some international
team with a bunch of geiger counters are
going to get in there and show that a
new quiz was pop but non-persistent
chemical agents you know the yellow
remains that the afghans talked about
they can use those and you know have
enough plausible deniability that the
international community might look a
little askance at them but can't really
prove that they've been using them you
know and they try to leverage that
technological advantage of theirs just
like we were trying to leverage all the
technological advantages we had thinking
that that's going to somehow translate
all these technologies will translate
into some kind of strategic advantage
but we never really address and the
Soviets never really addressed who it is
they're fighting and they've got another
they've got again you mentioned the
contrast what is the center of gravity
that they're going against at least we
could focus on hand away that might have
been the wrong focus for us but at least
we could focus on annoy
where are the Soviets to focus on with
all these factions that that the
Mujahideen cuts this stuff there you
have some brother supply I think must be
very hurtful talk about Afghanistan as
being a so Vietnam I think the contrasts
are far more points in that case
in the first place it's very difficult
to have some outside support for
insurgent force in Afghanistan yes the
United States and a few other countries
support the Mashhadi morally
diplomatically politically and minimally
with some material help but it's never
significant it's never enough to tip the
balance one way or the other there there
are other problems in drawing this
comparison one is the fact that the
Soviets are bolstering on failed regime
in Rodian slip there they certainly were
bolstering failed regime income exactly
and that was that was something that had
wide-ranging diplomatic and political
consequences the issue of legitimate for
the Soviets because the Kabul government
is disliked by 95 to 98 percent of
population there's no way you're gonna
sell it to them and you have Gerry and I
have been there is extraordinarily
difficult to communicate from one place
to the very very minimal infrastructure
road network the ability to move is very
restricted and so whenever the Soviets
tried to reinforce order to develop
areas in which to operate their funnel
down very very few roads which can be
easily interdicted which which is a very
different problem within the borders of
the South Vietnam now we have problems
in Southeast Asia and interdicting
material flowing down the Ho Chi Minh
Trail but that's a political problem not
necessarily an operational problem so I
think you have to be careful in making
that that comparison
another is as you point out the
tradition of the Afghans very fiercely
independent people
which which is something that was not
true of the the people the former French
colonies in Indochina and so that must
be borne in mind as well I think
compared to our American Revolution I
think a lot of the people in North
Vietnam and South Vietnam during the
French struggle and the struggle with us
being there what kind of like the silent
majority they went on to be left alone
and everybody's trying to convince them
to join the side not in Afghanistan
another problem is this is something
that we only have a better understanding
in retrospect and that is the Soviet
Union was never as viable and strong as
we always thought it would be already in
the 1970s so very serious economic
problems those economic problems will
ultimately help bring down the Soviet
Union in the 1980s and those problems
are already living the Soviets in the
1970s we have our problems completely in
the United States
in the 1960s and the early nineteen
seventies the Soviets have their
problems but we have a viable means of
transferring power that is through
elections and constitutional systems so
it's yet to resolve that issue for
themselves and the Brezhnev government
for example has a problem as Brezhnev
it's older lower and less and less
capable of governing what's going to
happen
who's going to come to power what are
their policies going to be if we have
our problems in establishing long term
policies the Soviet system has multiple
problems understand establishing those
long term policies and so we need to
take all that into consideration as well
so I I think that it's perhaps a
misnomer to go too far with this
comparison between America that's a good
point I think it's time to close up one
of the things I think you might consider
is you compare this to the 19th century
Europe was gobbling up the rest of the
world it's going back to the
International City we're in an era of
post-world War two
with the notion of self-determination
people have a right to choose their own
governments look at the United Nations
formed by us controlled by us at the
beginning and then hundred new nations
almost virtually hundred new nations
appear and they attack us now the United
Nations it's the wave of wars of
national liberation people struggling
for independence within the context of
the Cold War where one side is fighting
against the other side usually the
superpowers come in once I think one
side the other takes the other side we
find in Vietnam the Soviets are giving
the need to the support that the North
Vietnamese need to fight us and it's not
a popular war to be and around the world
the same way in Afghanistan the Soviets
find the world weight of the world is
against them so it's not that we're
let's say Dumber the people in 19th
century who seemed a little more
successful back then there was a
monopoly on the Gatling gun at a time
there was less a rivalry to undo the guy
in trying to get a colonial state what
kind of dividing the world in stones of
influence and then grabbing colonies
along the way that has changed the force
of self-determination has emerged
grabbing territory for someone else
exchanging lands here and there which
used to be the way things were done in
Europe before no longer seems to operate
so it's in a different climate
international setting strategic
environment that the Vietnamese war in
the Afghan war are fought and it does
influence tremendously how you actually
fight at the point of the arrow you
can't ignore the larger environment
communications
values international diplomacy all those
things they weigh in and how these wars
are conducted thank you very much
you